cercueil de nelson mandela qui est
arrivée dans son village natal de qunu
l'avion militaire qui transportait la
dépouille de l'ancien président s'était
posé un petit peu plus tôt à l'aéroport
en fait dans sa province natale du cap
oriental
alors à son arrivée à l'aéroport
le cercueil a été accueilli par un
parterre de dignitaires parmi lesquels
sa femme graça machel
alors donc le cortège est présentement
dans le village de son enfance à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de l'aéroport
là où il sera enterré demain et là aussi
où se trouve notre envoyé spécial sophie
langlois
nous sommes aujourd'hui à qunu sur une
colline qui surplombe le village de
nelson mendela il a vécu son enfance ici
et il a souvent dit qu'il avait vécu à
qunu les plus belles années de sa vie
il adorait les montagnes qu'on voit tout
autour mais il aimait surtout la vie
paisible des paysans ici il a lui-même
d'ailleurs gardé les vaches et les
moutons de la famille alors la dépouille
du premier président noir d'afrique du
sud va arriver chez lui ici dans
quelques heures après avoir franchi une
procession alors la dépouille atterri à
l'aéroport de mthatha qui est à une
trentaine de kilomètres d'ici il y aura
il y a des milliers de sud africains qui
sont là pour lui faire un dernier adieu
le saluer personnellement parce que ce
sont dans ce cas si des gens dans
beaucoup de cas qu'ils ont
personnellement connu qui l'ont aimé et
qui ont profité aussi de sa présence de
façon très concrète ici on a parlé à des
gens de qunu ce matin qui nous disait
s'inquiéter de la suite parce qu'il a
été tellement généreux pour chacun des
villageois chacune des personnes de
cette grande région qu'il a adoré c'est
aussi ici qu'il avait choisi
venir vivre après avoir pris sa retraite
de la vie politique et c'est donc ici
qu'il avait exprimé le souhait d'être
enterré et ça se fera ici demain
derrière moi on voit un grand chapiteau
blanc c'est là qu'auront lieu les
funérailles d'état avec des dignitaires
une cérémonie un peu plus privé plus
traditionnel avec les chefs rossa aura
lui aussi lieu loin des caméras
de même que l'enterrement qui doit se
faire de façon très intime avec la
famille ou si loin des caméras
demain ici sophie langlois pour
radio-canada à qunu